>>Akshay Kannan: Hi, everyone.
Cool, the mic works.
Good afternoon, everyone.
Are you guys excited for the last session
of the day?
[ Cheering ].
>>Akshay Kannan: All right.
My name is Akshay Kannan, and I'm a PM on
the project.
>>Yuri Dolgov: And I'm Yuri Dolgov, and I'm
software engineer on the project.
>>Akshay Kannan: And today we're going to
talking to you about Google Cloud Print and
the future of printing.
So real quick just to give you an outline
of the presentation, we'll start with an introduction,
explain what Google Cloud Print is.
We'll talk about how you can integrate with
our application both to print from as well
as receive print jobs.
We'll talk about some of the formats we support
and finally we'll talk about our future plans
and where we're heading going forward.
So real quick just to get a show of hands,
how many of you guys in the audience have
heard of Google Cloud Print prior to Google
I/O?
Awesome.
Pretty much everyone.
Cool.
And how many of you guys have ever printed
something using Google Cloud Print before
coming here?
Awesome.
Most of you guys.
And how many of you have ever used our API
before?
All right.
A significantly smaller number of you.
So hopefully this talk will change that and
will give you a better idea of our API as
well as the platform as a whole.
So let's quick things off.
So at a very high level, Google Cloud Print
was a Web service that we at Google created
to take the pain out of printing.
We know that setting up a printer and printing
to a printer are some of the most troublesome
things that people have to deal with everyday
with computing, and we really wanted to make
that experience better.
So our high level goal with Cloud Print was
to provide a seamless, driverless printing
experience that worked regardless of what
platform you were on.
Pretty much as long as your device can connect
to the cloud you should be able to print without
running a full driver stack.
So in terms of our motivations and what drove
this, I'm going to take a trip back in time
to 2010, way back in the day when we were
designing Chrome OS and trying to find out
how to solve printing on that platform.
So printing is obviously really, really important
use case on the Chromebook.
It's a device that's designed for content
creation, and people need to print.
And so we were considering different models
for how to do this.
On one hand you have your traditional driver
model which you're accustomed to on your Windows,
Mac and Linux machine.
This was great because it was tried and true,
but there were a lot of trade-offs with this.
One major problem we saw is that we'd have
to package every single Chrome OS device that
we sold with a whole bunch of printer drivers
that you may or may not even use.
Especially for an action you perform not too
frequently, it doesn't make sense to have
this code sitting on every single device out
there.
I think another problem that we ran into with
drivers is just the fact that we would have
to keep them continuously updated.
If you got a new printer and it didn't have
the drivers that you needed on that device,
you would be dependent on Google or on your
printer manufacturer to release drivers that
were specific to your model, and that was
just a huge pain point and we didn't want
to deal with having this constant baggage
on every Chromebook that we'd have to keep
updated.
I think third of all, and most importantly,
Google has a lot of platforms that are important
on the cloud.
We have Chrome, we have Chrome OS, we have
Android.
And we didn't want to just come up with a
solution for one platform.
We wanted to come up with a solution that
would scale to a whole bunch of platforms.
And that was the beauty with Cloud Print is
because what we had was a Web service, we
were able to build something server side which
supported all the different platforms that
Google has.
And this is a comic I like.
It's an excerpt from The Oatmeal, which sort
of gives you an idea of some of the pain points
you run into with traditional driver installations,
and this is exactly what we want to avoid
with Google Cloud Print.
So this cool 3D diagram gives you sort of
a high level overview of how our system works
and what exactly it does.
There are a variety of devices you can print
from.
Some examples just given here are your tablet,
your Chromebook, your Android phone, your
iPhone, your -- or even your traditional Mac
or PC.
Your print jobs are sent to Google Cloud Print.
You can and them over any format and then
we convert them into the format they need
to be in for the destination printer.
So here are three examples of devices we can
send print jobs to.
Arrow A is pointing to a printer that is shared
through Google Cloud Print through an intermediary
laptop acting as a connector.
We'll explain more of that later.
Arrow B is pointing to a cloud-ready printer.
These are printers that talk directly to the
Google Cloud Print service from within their
firmware.
We have one of these printers up front and
will actually be doing some live printing
for you later.
And then Arrow C, which is basically you're
printing to an enterprise server, which could
be managing thousands of printers.
And we actually use a server very much like
this inside of Google to manage all of our
printers with employees.
So the great thing with Google Cloud Print,
and one of the reasons that -- I guess the
beauty of the platform and why we find it
so powerful is it allows you to do all kinds
of things that you could never really imagine
doing before with local printing.
So for one thing as an application developer,
to add printing functionality with your app
is as easy as three lines of code.
Yuri is going to be guiding you through that
at a later portion of the presentation.
But we've really made it really, really easy
for you as developers to plug into the platform
and integrate with Google Cloud Print.
Another advantage you have is because with
Cloud Print all your print jobs go through
the cloud, you can print not just to printers,
but actually to any device or application
which is connected to the cloud.
And we've built a lot of really interesting
products around this, which we'll be explaining
more later in the presentation as well.
Finally -- and this feature is something we
feel that is really powerful is that we've
made it dirt simple to share printers with
people.
I don't know how many of you guys have ever
tried to share a local printer with someone,
but it's not exactly a really fun process.
You can either do it through network sharing
and set up your computer as a server or you
can pass someone a USB cable in which case
they have to plug it in, go through a bunch
of driver installs and by the time they'll
get printing it will take forever.
So we've made sharing ridiculously easy, and
I'm actually going to show you a demo of that
real quick.
So the great thing with Cloud Print is we've
made sharing a printer as easy as sharing
a doc.
So here you can see the Cloud Print management
page in Google Chrome.
This is just google.com/cloudprint.
You can see I have three printers.
The printer that I have selected is actually
the printer in the front of the room.
This is our demo printer.
And if I want to share this printer with Yuri,
all I have to do is click the green share
button and you see a sharing dialogue just
like the one in Docs.
I type in Yuri's Gmail account, I hit enter
and I hit share and that's it.
I've just shared this printer with Yuri and
it was as easy as sharing a doc with him.
So because your printers are associated with
your Google account it allows us to make sharing
really simple and seamless.
And I guess as a fourth point also with Google
Cloud Print, because all your print jobs go
through the cloud, we're completely OS, device
and browser agnostic, so your printing experience
is going to be virtually identical whether
you're on your Android phone or whether you're
on your Windows PC.
You're gonna see the same print options, see
more or less the same dialogue, and we've
done this to provide a consistent experience
regardless of what platform you're on.
So I've given you a high level overview of
the platform and now I'm going to hand it
out to Yuri and he will explain how to integrate
with Cloud Print from within your apps.
>>Yuri Dolgov: Hey, guys.
I'm going to guide you through engineering
part of our presentation.
And I want to start with the limitations of
existing printing solutions on different platforms.
With Web platform nowadays you can pretty
much build whatever application you can think
of, but when it comes to something as printing,
and still there are many people who care about
getting their document printed, you are faced
with a whole bunch of different problems.
Pages look different on different Web browsers,
so you have to worry about making them look
the same on every single browser you basically
create your application for.
If you have mobile version of your Web application,
it's even worse because usually the mobile
version is different from desktop and you
might want to have printed version looks the
same as on desktop.
With mobile devices it's even worse.
For every single new platform you put your
variation to, you have to come up with different
printing solution.
And for some platforms you don't even have
standard solutions, you have to invent them
on your own, and that's what we are trying
to solve with Cloud Print.
With Cloud Print we want to provide you with
the same seamless printing experience on every
single platform.
Same API, same content type of the documents,
everything is the same on every single platform.
I want to start to use example of Web integration,
how you integrate Cloud Print in your existing
Web application.
For Web we have very simple, yet very powerful
way.
It's gadget based.
So basically first thing you need to do is
just load gadget code from this URL on to
your page.
And gadget cross-name is called print gadget.
It has only one static method, which is create
default print button, which creates default
button, which looks like this.
And if you create instance of this gadget
you can also use those methods listed before.
First of them is set on close callback, which
is pretty trivial, allows you to set on close
callback.
You can set any function that is going to
be called when print dialogue is closed.
The next one is set print button.
There it is.
And that one allows you to set whatever HTML
element you want to attach to bring the gadget
to.
You can use either button generated by this
method or you can use your own DOM, it doesn't
matter.
Whenever a user clicks on the DOM element,
a print dialogue is going to pop out.
Next -- and the main method of this gadget
is set print document, which allows you to
set documents that is going to be printed.
First parameter of that is content type, content
type of document you want to print.
Second one is title of the print job.
Third one is going to be used to identify
the job by the user in print queue.
Third one, and the main, is content of the
document.
And content can be both binary or Base64 encoded.
Though Base64 encoded version is a little
bit larger than binary version, you might
still want to prefer that in some cases, especially
if you have some kind of Native-to-JavaScript
breach, and in this case you might face jobs
of early string terminations or stuff like
that.
So you might sacrifice a slice and still use
Base64 encoded version of the document.
And if you decide to use Base64 encoded version
of the document you will need to set force
parameter, which is optional content in the
colon.
And in this case you will need to parse Base64
string.
If you want to have more control on opening
and closing print dialogue, you might want
to use two other -- two methods below.
It's open print dialogue and close print dialogue
which allows you to open and close print dialogue.
And you might want to use it if you want to
open print dialogue on some custom action
like print -- document was uploaded or -- and
conversion was done or registration finished,
stuff like that, so any custom events.
I want to go and show you how you do it in
an existing application.
This is just fragment of code.
Let's say (indiscernible).
It goes like here.
So the first thing you need to do is load
gadget code, as I said.
The next thing, in this example we use on
print function, which is going to be called
whenever a user wants to print a document.
The third thing we do in this function is
create a Cloud Print gadget instance.
The next thing we set print document you want
to print.
In this case we use the application PDF content
type, but we can use many others and we will
tell you more about that later.
And we said print job title, like my print
job title, something.
And this is Base64 encoded content of PDF.
And since this is Base64 encoded, we need
to set force parameter to Base64.
And then we just open print dialogue, and
that's it, we are done.
And one more thing I want to mention is that
this code you'll work exactly the same way
on any browser, including mobile browsers.
So you only implement it once and -- well,
we'll do everything for you.
We'll open different type of dialogues on
different browsers, depending on -- well,
optimize them for those.
Yeah.
And we want to show you how Box integrated
with us.
They basically took almost no time to do that.
I hope you know what Box is, all right?
It's file sharing, file storing service.
I have my Box account opened here and I have
only one document and I want to print it with
Cloud Print.
So I see it send to Google Cloud Print and
here I see print dialogue.
As you can see I have invitation to accept
a new printer.
The printer is actually shared with me a few
minutes ago.
I will go ahead and accept this printer.
There we go, printer is accepted, and now
we're going to use it to print this document.
You see the document was immediately sent
to the printer and it's going to be printed
like in a few seconds.
So it's super easy to integrate Web application
on Cloud Print and it's even easier to integrate
Android application with Cloud Print.
In order to do that you will need to include
Cloud Print intent code into your application,
and you can get this code on this URL --
[ Applause ].
>>Akshay Kannan: Sorry to interrupt.
To make matters even more interesting, this
printer is connected using a mobile network,
so -- yeah, everything seems to be connected.
[Laughter].
>>Yuri Dolgov: Okay.
I will continue this Android integration.
On Android, the integration is even simpler
than on the Web.
All we need to do is just add Cloud Print
intent into your application, and you can
get a code of this intent on this URL.
And the intent class name is cloud print dialogue.
And all we need to do is just illustrate this
intent, subdate it and type up the documents
you want to print, set titles of the document
you want to print and start the intent.
Since it's so that simple I want to go ahead
and show you how to do it in a real application.
In my case application is not that real.
This is Danny Web browser.
Thank you.
So it's Danny Web browser, and there is only
three URL elements, URL box, which is basically
a box where you can type URL you want to go
to.
Go button, which you need to click in order
to go to this URL.
And Web view, which is -- well, which contains
content of the Web page.
So you will see codes there.
It's very simple.
I don't want to spend too much time on that.
The only non-trivial part here is that we
have functionality to get HTML content on
the Web page, and in order to do that we need
to have JavaScript-to-Java bridge because
-- well, this is the only way you can access
Web view content.
Anyways, I'm going to compile and start this
application.
There we go.
So this is, as I said, very simple browser.
You can open the page, you can navigate, do
stuff like that.
Let's go ahead and integrate this Cloud Print.
What we need to do is just add the URL element.
You can click in order to open print dialogue.
In this case it's a button and I have it already
in my layout XML file, so I don't want to
spend time implementing, write it once again.
And they have (indiscernible) already.
I will go ahead and explain line by line what
we have here.
First thing we do is create print intent.
Then we find print button in the UI and set
on click listener.
So in on click listener what we do is just
get content of the Web page, set it as document
to be printed, along with content type, which
in this case that's HTML, set title of the
print job and start the activity.
That's pretty much it.
Let's look how it works.
So it should start in a second.
Here we go.
The connection is a bit slow.
Here you see a new button print.
We'll go ahead and click this button.
This will open print dialogue and you can
select printer you want to print to.
Let's use the same printer again.
Print.
And it should be instantly sent to printer.
No?
>>Akshay Kannan: There we go.
>>Yuri Dolgov: Okay.
Worked this time again.
Okay.
It's going to be printed in a few seconds,
so I'm going to continue with -- yeah, with
my presentation.
In some cases those two integrations might
not -- oh, by the way, yeah, you can get the
code of this presentation from here.
It's completely open.
You can check how it looks in details.
So in some cases those two integrations might
not be enough for you.
For example, you are working with some other
platform or you want to have some more flexibility,
doesn't matter.
We still have open APIs that you can use.
And there are three main API codes that you
need to know if you want to send a job to
Cloud Print.
First one is search.
It allows you to search for all the printers
available for the user.
You can do some filter and some searches,
like some filter -- like filter in by (indiscernible)
or by status for those printers, but after
all the goal is to provide user a list of
printers available for them.
Once user selects the printer they want to
print to, you need to do another code, printer
code, which will return capabilities of the
printer.
And you will need to show those capabilities
to the users so that they could select how
they want to print the job.
Once capabilities are selected, you would
need to do the third one, third call, which
is the certainly the main one.
That will submit a print job to printer, printer
is given printer ID, title of the job, capabilities,
content type, if -- if content of the job
is Base 64 encoder, so you will need to set
up a content task for encoding as well and
content itself.
So it's super easy again and with that I'm
going to hand it back to Akshay.
>>Akshay Kannan: Sounds good.
So we have showed how you can integrate with
that --
[ Applause ]
>>Yuri Dolgov: Thank you.
>>Akshay Kannan: So we have showed you how
we can integrate with Cloud Print, you can
use our Web widget, Android widget, or HTTP
API directly, we have really tried to make
it easy to bring that functionality into your
app.
That's printing from a lot of places, but
we actually also support printing to a lot
of places, printing to anywhere.
We have over 20 million printers that are
registered with Google Cloud Print as of today
and that number is continuing to grow, so
our main type of printers are -- at least
for the best user experience, we recommend
what we call cloud ready printers.
These are printers that connect directly to
the Web from within the firmware themselves.
We have over 70 cloud ready printer models
that are available from a wide variety of
retailers and manufacturers, and we've -- in
particular printers the list that we have
here on our slide deck of HP, Canon, Kodak,
Epson, Fuji Xerox and Samsung, are just the
manufacturers who have printers that are currently
available.
We are working with a much larger list of
manufacturers over time to expand this out.
So basically it will be hard at some point
to buy a printer that's not cloud ready.
We also have a full list of printers on our
Web site, g.co/cloudprint where you can check
out what printers are available.
And which ones are cloud ready.
I know a lot of you also probably don't want
to buy a new printer.
You just use Google Cloud Print, and the good
news is that you don't have to.
We support what's called the Chrome connector,
which allows you to take any local printer
that's connected to your printer running Chrome
and use that printer as a print server.
So how this works it's let's say that you
have Google Chrome running on your Windows
PC at home.
You can USB your printer into there, set it
up as a local printer.
And then from within Chrome settings, you
can register -- in fact here's a screen shot
from the settings dialogue, you just click
the add printers button right there, and it's
simply a one-click process.
Your local printers will automatically get
added to your Google Cloud Print account with
the account that you are logged in with.
So we do make it easy to set up printers that
are not cloud ready.
The only caveat here is that you do need to
keep your computer running in order for jobs
to be printed out.
That being said, if you submit a print job
to a computer that's turned off, it gets queued,
so next time you turn it on your job will
get released and printed out from the printer
that's connected to it.
Also we don't just support printer to printers,
as I mentioned earlier.
But we really support printing to anywhere.
You can print to -- currently every Google
Cloud Print dialogue has the option save to
Google drive, which will take whatever you
are printing, convert it to a PDF, and save
it in your Google drive account or you can
even print to a FedEx office, which is a partnership
we recently launched this year which allows
you to print your document and get a retrieval
code, which you can use to basically print
out and pay for your job at any local Fed-Ex
office location within the U.S.
Finally, another little exciting feature that
we have is the ability to print to your mobile
phone.
So if you have Chrome for mobile installed
on Android or iOS and you are signed into
sync, what we do is we actually register your
phone as a Google Cloud Print device in your
dialogue.
So what you will be able to do -- whenever
you are printing from Cloud Print, if you
are using the same account that you have set
up your phone with, you will see your phone
as a destination that you can print to.
And what we do is we just push an Android
push notification that the job is available
and it gets downloaded to your phone.
So this is already available today and you
guys can try it out.
Finally, in terms of printing to anywhere,
we also -- like most of our product -- have
a fully open API that you can use as developers
to receive print jobs.
So we have an XMPP interface, which you can
connect to in order to receive print job notifications.
And we also have a full set of HTTPS interfaces
that you can connect to to basically fetch
the job, set job status.
And I'll delve into the details in the next
slide.
Cloud ready printers such as the one you can
see on stage have already implemented this
in firmware.
So it's real easy to implement whether you
are working with low-level hardware or building
an application.
Yeah, really, any application or device can
implement this.
And so we leave the possibilities of integration
up to the developer.
And a lot of this really allows you to use
your imagination for what you can print to.
Some examples we just thought of are you could
print to your Kindle.
You could build an application that would
allow you to print documents for reading on
the go.
You could technically build an application
that would even allow you to print to a smart
Web connected TV.
And if monkeys were cloud connected, then
you could even print to a monkey with a typewriter.
That one might require more imagination than
the others.
So just to go into the details of our API,
there's two API calls you really call about
with our job retrieval.
There's our fetch API, which takes in a printer
ID as an argument, so you would call to fetch
API when you receive an XMPP ping that a job
is available.
And what the fetch API does is it returns
a JSON list of the jobs that are available
to be printed.
In this JSON object for each job, we have
two parameters that are important, the fie
URL parameter and the ticketURL parameter.
The fileURL parameter, which is the one right
here, is basically a URL that you can use
to download the file.
So the cool thing about this URL is that -- you
can -- you can dynamically change the format
of the file by specifying a different accept
header when you are fetching this URL.
So for example, if you want to fetch the job
as a PDF, you set your accept header to be
application PDF, then we will convert the
document to a PDF server site and send it
to your printer.
If you want to fetch it -- the other main
format is PWG Raster, which is a simple Raster
based image format.
If you want to fetch that, you just set your
accept header to PWG Raster and we will stream
the file to you in that format.
And then finally ticketURL is basically your
print ticket that contains a list of the filled
options of exactly what the user specified.
For example, portrait or landscape or whatever
other capabilities you have exposed from your
printer that are configurable.
Our second API, which is important is our
control API, which allows you to basically
update the status of the job as you're printing
it.
So by default, whenever you print a job, we
set the status of that job to be queued.
And over time as you are printing that -- so
for example, when you start to fetch, you
can set the job, move the status from queued
to be in progress, and then when you are done
printing the job, you can move the status
to done.
If something goes wrong, you can also set
the status to error, and specify an error
of coded message string.
Finally we do take security and privacy really
seriously with Google Cloud Print and one
example of how we do this is we have a secure
data access model, such that every item within
our system, whether it's a printer, whether
it's a print job is (indiscernible), so that
you can only print to that if you have explicit
permissions as your account to send a print
job there.
So all of the APIs that we mentioned earlier
are authenticated so you have to be logged
in as a user who has explicit privileges to
access that.
So we earlier said that you could print to
anything, but that was a lie because we have
security restrictions in place.
Finally, we also support so -- so this is
actually I'll start with the problem here
is when you are dealing with printer registrations,
registration is an API that's difficult to
make an authenticated call because it requires
the printer to somehow authenticate as you
before it can register itself with the system.
That's a hard problem, because -- the biggest
concern for is it's a security issue because
you could have printers when you are typing
credentials into the printer that could store
them locally unencrypted on the device, make
it vulnerable to attackers who could steal
your Google account from the printer.
And then also I think on another folder also
the UI problem of not all printers -- not
all printers support text entry on their device.
So we've solved this using what we call the
anonymous registration flow.
This allows the printer to basically make
an unauthenticated registration call to our
servers, which anonymously registers the printer
to Google Cloud Print.
In order to actually complete the registration
process, we have returned a URL to the printer,
which the printer can then print out and give
to the user and the user can visit that URL
on their Web browser and complete the registration
process from there.
We know that this is secure because you are
only entering your credentials into a Google
log-in page and not into a third party interface.
And then finally there's also robot accounts,
which are special accounts that we create
just for printers in our system when the registration
happens.
The nice thing with robot accounts is that
they are sandboxed, so they are only given
restricted access to Google Cloud Print and
can't access other things in your Google account
that you wouldn't want them to.
Finally, all of our interfaces use HTTPS and
we strongly encourage you as developers to
also use the HTTPS versions of our API.
Finally, regarding privacy, another problem
that we've dealt with is spam invitations.
So, for example, if I shared -- I could technically
share 100 printers with Yuri and completely
spam his account.
Another possible attack is that I could share
a printer, which looks like one of Yuri's
printers to him, and he could end up printing
to that and I could steal all of his data
as a result.
So one thing to prevent this is we have implemented
printer sharing invitations.
So this, as you saw earlier, requires Yuri
to explicitly accept my printer sharing invitation
before he can print to a printer.
As part of that invite process, he sees exactly
who I am and the name of the printer that
I'm sharing with him, so this prevents you
from getting spammed with printers and also
prevents you from printing to printers unless
you are absolutely sure that you have accepted
an invitation and that you know who sent you
that invite.
And then finally regarding print job content
retention, we delete for jobs as soon as the
status is set to done.
If the status is never set to done, then after
30 days, we delete print job content from
our servers.
We don't store them long term.
Finally, we've talked about how you can print
from anywhere, how you can print to pretty
much anywhere, and I'm going to go into another
part of our presentation which is how you
can print anything.
We do support a very, you know, Google Cloud
Print was developed with sort of developers
in mind.
And client platforms in mind.
And we realized that when you are generating
documents client side, you don't want to be
bound to a particular format that you have
to generate.
You want to have the flexibility to generate
your content in whatever formant you want
and then send it server side where we can
do the necessary conversion.
So for this reason, our API accepts virtually
any format as input for your print job.
So you can send us pdfs, stand image formats,
most standard document formats, Google docs,
Microsoft Office documents, HTML documents
or even URLs which we can fetch server side
and NET Frame.
On our side, we make our best effort to convert
this document into either PDF or PWG Raster.
Another thing that's interesting, if you don't
care about conversion, then our platform -- if
the input and output formats are identical,
we will actually do no conversion whatsoever
and simply pass the file through our system.
This could be really useful if you wanted
to do something like make a 3D Cloud Printer
that used a special format, as long as the
format that you in which you are submitting
the job and receiving the job in are the same,
our system will just pass the job content
right through.
It's also particularly useful for sending
-- if you want to encrypt content and before
you send it to us, decrypt it after you receive
it, you could send us a custom encrypted format,
which we would pass directly through without
doing any conversion on whatsoever.
Then, finally, one format that I wanted to
focus on that I think is particularly powerful
is HTML.
It's a format that's easy to create client
side and sent to us on the server side.
The other great thing about HTML is there's
no direct page content that's here or I guess
page layout information.
So it allows us server side to intelligently
flow the HTML, depending on what media size
of paper that you are printing to.
So, for example, if you are in the U.S. and
you are printing to an 8 and a half by 11
page, we will flow the HTML text and images
for an 8 and a half by 11 paper and generate
the appropriate PDF server side.
If you are in some other and country and using
A4, then we would flow the HTML content for
an A4 and send that to you, so as an application
you wouldn't even have to worry about the
media size of the destination printer that
you are sending content to.
So I'm now going to just spend a little bit
of time talking about our future work and
where we're heading going forward with Google
Cloud Print.
So -- so one huge challenge for us has been
handling printer capabilities.
There's -- they can be kind of a nightmare
to deal with.
There's a lot -- basically with printer capabilities,
the two main formats are XPS and PPD.
And the thing that makes them interesting
as well, there are standards.
Printer manufacturers only have to write capabilities
such that they'll work with their particular
driver.
So for this reason, there can be a lot of
ways to specify the same option.
Even an option as simple as portrait or landscape
specified differently on different platforms.
So we really -- what we want to do is rather
than just reading strings, we want to be a
able to intelligently understand these capabilities,
make sense of them, produce good options UI
around them, and also even surface some of
this functionality to developers.
So that as an application developer, you can
know about the printer that you are sending
jobs to at a high level without having to
parse these capabilities yourself.
So that's one of our big goals going forward
is to more intelligently understand these
different capabilities and be able to semantically
parse them on our side.
Real quick here, you can see our server's
JSON representation or an excerpt from our
server's JSON representation of an XPS capability,
we will see an idea of what that's like.
Another big goal that we're working towards
are making public and commercial printers
that you can print to ubiquitous.
We really like the concept of being able to
print even without owning a printer, no matter
where you are.
We did launch a partnership with the Fed-Ex
office, as I mentioned earlier, which makes
this possible.
Another thing, if you guys are on the first
floor of Moscone, we do have a Cloud Print
station, which we have set up, to allow you
to print to public printers.
You can print to these printers simply by
tapping an NFC tag or scanning a QR code,
it gives you -- instantly adds the printer
to your Google account and allows you to start
sending print jobs to it.
And then, finally, one of our biggest and
most exciting goals and moving forward is
we want Cloud Print to be tightly integrated
with other Google properties.
So you can come to expect the same consistent
printing experience, regardless of what Google
platform you are using.
One feature that I'm about to give you a sneak
preview of is some of the work that we've
been doing in Google Chrome to tightly integrate
Cloud Print with the local printing experience
in Chrome and just make that seamless.
So real quick, I'm going to grab the laptop
and open up the -- this is the Canary channel
of Chrome, it's updated nightly.
This is a pretty risky demonstration.
So what we're going to do is we're going to
try printing our own API documentation using
the new Cloud Print dialogue that we're working
on.
So I'm just going to hit command P. It's going
to open the dialogue that you all know and
love, except there's a slight difference.
And that is -- I don't know if you guys can
notice, the destination pane is slightly different
from what you are used to.
And by the way, this is all available on dev
channel today, so you guys can check this
out for yourselves.
So what's going to happen here is I'm going
to click change, this pops up something different
from the usual drop-down.
It actually pops down a screen where your
local printers and your Cloud Printers are
integrated side by side.
What's happened is because I'm signed into
Chrome as cloudprint.user@gmail.com, I'm able
to see my Google Cloud Print printers.
You with see from within the Chrome dialogue,
I can see save to Google drive, I can see
print to Fed-Ex office and I can see the printer
that's been shared with me, which is the Cloud
Print demo printer.
This guy up front.
So what I'm going to do is for the sake of
this demo, I'm going to choose the Cloud Print
demo printer.
I'm going to hit print.
And what happens is this document is posted
to the Cloud Print service and then sent to
the printer, which should be printing it out
any second.
So this is our integration in Chrome and it's
-- you know, we've tried to make it as seamless
as possible, basically as easy to print to
Cloud Print as it is to print to a local printer.
And this is just one of the many integrations
that you will see across Google properties
going forward, so we are really excited for
that.
So actually, once this prints out, that concludes
the end of our presentation.
Thank you so much for coming.
We're going to leave the remaining 20 minutes
for Q and A. So -- so -- so fire away.
[ Applause ]
>>Akshay Kannan: All right.
We will start the right side of the room.
>>> Hi.
I had one question.
On the Android apps and on the Web.
Is there a way to -- to take away some of
the options in the printing, especially the
number of copies that are printed?
My app requires that the user be able to print
something only once.
So is there a way to suppress the number of
copies that you can print?
>>Akshay Kannan: So the question was whether
it's possible to restrict certain options
within the Android dialogue and within other
dialogues to not show options such as copies.
Actually --
>>Yuri Dolgov: No, there is not such a way.
But, yeah, this is nice suggestion.
We'll -- we'll discuss it.
>>> Is there a way to actually suppress it
using the HTTPS protocols?
I mean, I don't --
>>Yuri Dolgov: If you create your own, your
custom print dialogue, you can suppress whatever
you want.
But in this case, you have to parse capabilities
yourself.
>>> Yeah, that's fine.
>>Akshay Kannan: So you can do it using the
HTTPS API and basically not show certain options
in your UI.
>>> Thanks.
>>> You mentioned that you have millions of
Cloud Print printers on your system now.
Can you speak a little bit about the infrastructure
required for that?
Do you have millions of TCP connections that
are open, using UDP or how does that work?
>>Akshay Kannan: For our cloud ready printers
we are using XMPP to handle the notifications
between us and those printers.
There isn't necessarily a one-to-one correspondence
of XMPP connections to printers.
Because a lot of times with the Chrome connector,
with Cloud Print servers, you have multiple
printers which can be associated with a single
connection.
So -- so what it is, for cloud ready printers,
we have one XMPP connection for each of those
printers.
And for printers that are connected to the
server or a different Chrome connector, it's
an XMPP connection per machine.
So -- so, for example, if I'm sharing five
printers with my MacBook, I'd have five XMPP
open or, I'm sorry, one XMPP connection controlling
all five of those printers.
>>> But just short questions -- the short
answer to your question is we keep millions
connected, connections open on our site, for
every single printer, and we rely on your
infrastructure for that.
So, yes.
>>> So if my office just lost its internet
connection because a cable chewed on the wire,
all I can do is stare at my Cloud Printers,
correct.
>>Akshay Kannan: What happens is when your
printers are offline, any job goes into a
queued state, so everyone would still be able
to print, but then once the internet comes
back on, all the jobs would come back out
of the printer.
>>> I cannot send jobs directly to the print,
they have to go through Google.
No connection to Google, no printing.
>>Akshay Kannan: Yeah.
>>> Got it.
Thank you.
>>> Is there a Linux print server for this,
or windows print server, short of leaving
Chrome open on the server?
>>Akshay Kannan: There is, actually, so on
Linux, how it works is you can start the Chrome
connector, but actually you can run Chrome
in -- this is actually -- it's in the chromium
source.
I'm not sure how much of this is documented.
We'll probably be documenting over time.
But you can run Chrome in a headless mode
with a certain command line flag, which will
start the Cloud Print service up in the background,
and it's what we do internally at Google to
get all of our thousands of printers online.
So it doesn't require you to keep Chrome running;
it just requires you to have Chrome installed,
and you launch it with the flag which starts
up the Cloud Print service in the background.
>>> I've noticed that sometimes the office
printer that I Cloud Print to doesn't appear
in the dialogue box.
I assume that's because it's kind of a flakey
printer and sometimes it's offline or broken
or something, but I didn't see in your API
that there was a way for a printer to report
its status, or how does that -- how does Google
know that that printer is not available?
>>Akshay Kannan: So what we do is for status,
we actually determine that using your XMPP
status.
So if the printer doesn't have an active connection,
in fact you could see this, if I turn the
printer off right now, it will show up as
offline in the dialogue.
We basically use the XMPP status of the printer
to determine whether it's online or offline.
>>> So that doesn't remove from the list,
though?
Is there some --
>>Akshay Kannan: It doesn't remove from the
list.
What it does is it grays it out and it moves
it to the bottom of the list, so your online
printers show up above your offline printers,
but you'll still be able to see your offline
printers at any time.
If you're actually not seeing the printer,
then it might be that you're logged in with
a different account.
You have to be logged in with the same account
that you used to set up the printer, or you
can share the printer with your other account.
But, yeah, we don't -- the printer, if you
set it up once, it will always be part of
your account so...
>>> So you mentioned for security, once a
job is complete, you delete it.
Is there any ability to retain that for at
least a short period so that you could reprint
successful jobs?
>>Akshay Kannan: So one thing you can do is
if you are the printer receiving the jobs,
if you want to reprint successful jobs, we
only delete the job content when the status
gets set to done, so if you're the developer,
you could just set the status to be "in progress",
or move it from "in progress" back into queued,
and with all of these different states we
would retain the job on our side.
>>> I guess what I would like to see is -- is
that ability when you're using the connector,
so you've got an existing printer, but that
capability magically from your end.
>>Akshay Kannan: Sorry, I didn't catch exactly
that.
>>> So maybe just the ability to automatically
keep a copy of everything you print in the
drive, so not choosing one or the other, but
archive.
>>Akshay Kannan: I see.
I see.
That would definitely be interesting looking
into.
I know there's definitely document retention
and privacy implications around that as well,
because not everyone wants all their print
jobs saved, but it's definitely something
worth looking into.
>>> Thanks.
>>> I love Google Cloud Print by the way,
but my question is say you're in Google Drive,
and you have a picture file, I think if you
print it now, it like -- it just comes out
in a standard way.
Are you guys like thinking of any options
-- like if you wanted a full page photo or
like half page or like -- is there a way to
format it?
>>Akshay Kannan: So currently your formatting
options are limited to what the printer service
is and the capabilities.
Definitely over time we'll be expanding what
those capabilities are.
Some things like scaling would be options
that are -- that are part of the dialogue,
but I think for now the best approach is to
client side just generate the PDF how you
want it to look or just flow the image how
you want it to look and then send it to our
service, but, yeah, definitely it's future
work for us, but not currently there.
>>> At -- on my home system if I'm not logged
in, and I see my son is logged in on the computer,
I can't print.
Is there any work to have like an appliance
that could just sit on the network, you know,
a tiny little box that would prevent -- or
provide the cloud services so that I don't
have to worry about being logged in?
>>Akshay Kannan: There's -- that's definitely
a -- something that's -- a developer could
technically build.
We currently don't have anything like that.
>>Yuri Dolgov: We have source implementation
for WRT support, in just -- it's in early
stage, but (indiscernible) we implemented
this, and the problem he faced is basically
a drivers problem.
This implementation supports pretty much every
file as I remember, and, well, maybe something
else, but it won't support like every single
printer.
And it's hard to implement one that will support
every single printer.
>>> Where would I find that?
>>Akshay Kannan: Currently we don't link to
it from anywhere, but we can talk to you after
the presentation.
It's currently a project that's just on Google
code that was published by another Google
engineer who built this as an enthusiastic
side project.
>>> So kind of back to the scaling.
Say you have a printer that doesn't print
8.5 x 11, and you print an image or a PDF,
what happens?
Does that get scaled down up to the media,
or does it print at some, you know, fixed
resolution conversion?
>>Akshay Kannan: I believe some of that depends
on the printer you're printing to.
If there's a fit-to-page option, then we currently
service that and allow you to scale it down
to whatever the output format is.
Otherwise, I think the default behavior is
just to print it out exactly how it is, so
it might not be perfectly aligned when you're
trying to print and 8.5 x 11 PDF on your A4
paper.
That is the current behavior.
I think going forward we'll be working on
expanding fit-to-page capabilities.
But that's why we were also mentioning the
ideal experience rather than scaling is you
want your document to be reflowed which is
why we do recommend HTML for document submissions
because we can intelligently flow that for
whatever printer it's ending up on.
>>> But you don't necessarily have control
over what that source content is, if you want
to print some third party content that you
were just browsing to, say?
>>Akshay Kannan: Yes, if it's -- if it's,
for example, a PDF that's 8.5 x 11 that you
want to print to A4 paper, then our best options
there are fitting to page or printing it out
as it is, so we won't be able to intelligently
reflow that in that case.
>>> Okay, thanks.
>>> Can you please talk a bit more about the
setup you had on the first floor?
Can I make one of my printers public?
>>Akshay Kannan: Currently the setup we have
on our first floor is actually just part of
a pilot that we're running to try and make
printers public, so none of this UI is currently
available.
That being said, depending on the -- we're
basically trying this out as a pilot to see
how people interact with it.
I think moving forward it might be something
that we pursue more seriously and open up
to developers and to users.
>>> If my printer is not cloud ready, how
do I print to it?
>>Akshay Kannan: So if your printer is not
cloud-ready, you can set up the Chrome connector,
so this is -- or there's a slide earlier.
Basically from within the -- if your printer
is connected to a desktop or a laptop at home,
you can go to Chrome settings and enable from
advanced options, Google cloud print connector,
which will take that printer and then share
it with your Google account using that local
machine as a print server.
>>> The printer cannot be a network printer?
>>Akshay Kannan: It could be a network printer,
as long as -- the only restriction is that
the laptop or the computer that you're using
as the Cloud Print connector has to be able
to see that printer locally or over the network.
It has to be part of the OS print dialogue.
>>> Okay, thanks.
>>> If the page has a specific CSS layout
for print media, will the print Cloud Print
--
>>Yuri Dolgov: Specific print and layout so,
yes.
>>> And also your https rasts API, can I set
the orientation program -- like orientation
equals landscape or --
>>Yuri Dolgov: Oh, yeah, it depends on the
printer.
If printer supports orientation, we'll show
orientation.
If printer doesn't support orientation, we
don't do anything.
>>> No, no, I mean, I guess certain printers
-- for some reason it has to do with drivers
that's not -- exposed the API for software
to control whether it always asks the user
what orientation, but were you able to experiment?
Have you done it to programmatically set the
--
>>> With most printers you are able to programmatically
set the orientation using the capabilities,
basically when you get your -- when you fetch
the capabilities for that printer, you can
find the ones which correspond to orientation,
set them in your print ticket, and then when
you do your submit call, you can specify that
print ticket with the orientation specified.
>>> Thanks.
>>> So you mentioned some esoteric encryption
solutions where I would implement my -- a
shared key or something with my clients.
If I need an end-to-end security where Google
never sees my content, would I have to do
that, or is there another option?
>>Akshay Kannan: Yeah.
So, as I mentioned earlier, you can -- yeah,
with end-to-end security such that we never
see your content, the best solution currently
that we have is for you to encrypt it client
side and decrypt after receiving it.
The disadvantage there is you lose the functionality
for us to convert the document because we
can't read it, but it would be completely
invisible to us in that case.
>>> Thanks.
>>> Hi, you said raster data is either PDF,
is there any plan to support XPSS or --
>>Akshay Kannan: The question was is there
plans to support XPS as an output format.
The answer is currently no.
We're always looking into new formats to explore,
but for the -- for the foreseeable future,
PDF and PW Raster are our primary formats
going forward.
>>> Is it because XPS is from Microsoft?
[ Laughter ]
>>Akshay Kannan: I'm not going to comment
on that.
>>> So kudos on Cloud Print.
It's a very useful facility.
We have a network, a guest network that we
let people connect in on, and we have our
printers on our private network.
So Cloud Print helps with that, being able
to not have them on the same network, but
one of the issues is is being able to print
from Word or other OS-level type printers.
There's an open source piece of software that
lets you do that, but apparently with that
piece of software it only lets you print one
copy at a time.
Is there going to be anything supported by
Google that would allow, you know, printing
from OSB first class, first class printing,
like from Mac OS or --
>>Akshay Kannan: We -- yeah, we currently
don't have any plans to announce in that direction,
but that's definitely something that -- that
we're looking into going forward, and currently
I guess the one way to get around the fact
that that isn't currently there is to save
it as a PDF and then print it through Cloud
Print in Chrome, but, yeah, there's -- we
currently don't have stuff to announce but
--
>>> It makes the -- the wife acceptance factor
pretty low when you have to go through and
do those kind of gyrations.
>>Akshay Kannan: Absolutely.
>>> The second thing is is someone had mentioned
about a device like one of the things I toyed
around with is using raspberry pie and putting
Google Cloud Print on something like that.
Is anyone at Google or on your team interested
in doing something like that, or would they
support developers that were interested in
doing a project like that?
Because that seems like that would be an ideal
solution to provide printers, especially if
you have a large investment in Legacy printers
that you don't want to replace with Google
Cloud Printers.
>>Akshay Kannan: Yeah.
Absolutely.
As I mentioned, we did have an engineer who
put together a reference implementation of
a Cloud Print server on a router, and that
is all open source on Google code, so I can
hand you my contact information or you can
message the Google groups and we'll be happy
to point you to the code, and also put you
in touch with the guy who wrote it so --
>>> Okay.
Cool.
Thanks.
>>> On that side.
>>> I think he was before me.
>>> All right.
I have two questions.
First question is how do you handle updates
to capabilities?
For example, you know, you have a server that
got upgraded to handle duplex printing or
the toners are completely out, you can't print
anymore.
Is it over XMPP?
>>Akshay Kannan: So actually, we have an up
-- I didn't mention this API, but we do have
an update API which allows you to do exactly
that.
It's basically an https call that the printer
makes.
You specify new capabilities, what's changed
since last time, and we'll automatically update
all of that server side.
>>> That's over the tags, then?
>>Akshay Kannan: That's over https.
>>> And the second question is -- I forgot.
All right, I'll come back.
>>> Okay, so my questions are that when you
have multiple printers it's -- it gets quite
hard to determine if they are -- you have
the three different connectivity options,
and it's very hard to determine which of them
are connected in which ways, or at least used
to be.
So what's your opinion on that, and in windows
environments, in -- at least in Windows 7,
you can get an image of the printer so you
can see, oh, that's -- that's one.
Are there any developments in that direction?
>>Akshay Kannan: So I guess a couple of different
approaches we have are we do in our dialogue
use iconography to distinguish different types
of printers.
We also have a rename functionality that users
can use on their side to name the printer
such that you can differentiate between different
printers.
I don't know if there's anything else I'm
forgetting that kind of helps along these
lines, but we have a couple of solutions in
place.
I know there's also a description field that
you can specify as part of the printer which
will show up in the print dialogue which you
can use to differentiate different printers.
>>> Okay.
Thank you.
Would it be possible to group printers like
on departments on functionality-wise, or it
could also be -- say if you have a mobile
device or it feels that, okay, you're in this
city or in this office, then these are the
available printers from the ones that are
close nearby?
>>Akshay Kannan: So currently the answer to
that is no, but we do sort of have a solution
in place which is our search, our search in
our Cloud Print Web dialogue search is not
only over printer names but over capabilities
and description fields.
So one thing we do for example in Google is
every printer has a description field for
the building that it's in, so all I have to
do is type my building name into the search
dialogue and I'll see all the printers that
are near me.
Another thing is we also do -- I think you
mentioned grouping by capabilities, or what
options a printer can do, we do search over
those as well, so if you search for I only
want to see color printers, you can type in
color and just get a list of printers which
can print to color.
>>> Okay, so new employees at Google, you
have like a thousand printers in your dialogues.
>>Akshay Kannan: Uh-huh.
>>> Okay.
Then you search for nearby --
>>Akshay Kannan: Exactly.
>>> Okay.
>>Yuri Dolgov: You usually only use a couple
of them, and once you use printer, they will
be on top basically.
So you only need to do search once or twice.
>>> Thank you.
>>> When you submit print jobs, you have to
be locked in in the browser or in Android.
Is there any way that a server application
might be able to submit print jobs?
The case I have, all the use case where we
might be able to use this is one of our clients
runs a E commerce site, and they would love
to be able to use Cloud Print to print older
notifications as they come in.
>>Yuri Dolgov: You can do that.
You can create any account that you can share
the printer with, and then just using AUTH,
you can authenticate server with this account
and totally submit this account.
>>> Okay.
>>Akshay Kannan: Yeah, we support both AUTH
and client login for authentication, so you
could use that server side to authenticate
into our API with a dummy Google account and
then use that to submit print jobs.
>>> Excellent.
Thank you.
>>Akshay Kannan: Sure.
>>> Okay.
I'm wondering what kind of data has Google
extract from my print jobs?
Because privacy (indiscernible) but there
must be some other reasons to process data.
>>Akshay Kannan: If the source and destination
formats of your print job are the same, so
let's say you're printing a PDF to a PDF,
absolutely nothing.
We just send the document over to the printer
without any conversion on our side.
In terms of -- so in terms of conversion,
we do use a conversion service to convert
your document to the format it needs to be
in, but, yeah, as I mentioned before, the
converted document will not persist on our
server for more than 30 days.
The only thing I guess that stays left over
are standard http logs, and also I guess the
fact that within your account you'll see these
-- you'll see your print job history.
>>> So Google has no content extraction kind
of -- if I print my bank account statements
it's not --
>>Akshay Kannan: Not at all.
We don't use your print jobs to serve ads.
[ Laughter ]
>>> Is there any update on the Android as
an official Cloud Print, because as I recall,
it was still something that was semi unofficial.
>>Akshay Kannan: So, yeah, we are working
on integrating with the Android properties
of Google Apps going forward, but as far as
platform integration goes, we don't have anything
to announce at the moment.
>>> And then secondly, I think this has been
asked about three or four different ways,
at least, but I'm not sure that I got it completely
straight.
In our office, for instance, we have a large
group of people that come in and out, and
we have Legacy printers, and I didn't really
want to leave the Legacy printer connected
to a machine on my account, since I'm not
there all the time, amongst other things,
but also the machines themselves are generally
public, so I ended up putting it on one of
the administrator's -- one of the administrator's
accounts and leaving it there, but it doesn't
seem to be any way to have that done without
having a specific account which you then can
delegate out of.
That's, I think, the summarization of everything
that I've heard.
>>Akshay Kannan: In terms of accounts are
you referring to like log-in accounts?
>>> They have to have a Gmail account in order
to be able to have a printer -- in order to
be able to attach it to a legacy printer,
which they can then share.
And there's no other way around that that
I can figure.
>>> Just in general, enterprise printing I
guess would be the question and how do you
take a set of enterprise printers and let
a specific set of people or even make it public,
which is kind of what you're doing downstairs.
Is that going to be available soon or when
is that going to be available?
>>Akshay Kannan: I guess in terms of both
questions, with having an account in order
to register a printer, you do need a Google
account in order to register your printer
with Cloud Print.
That being said, it doesn't have to be your
Google account or someone else's.
A lot of the enterprises that we work with,
to answer your question, use what they call
a roll account, which is just a dedicated
Google account that they set up for the express
purpose of printing that they can share access
to, and they'll use that to run the print
server so that way no one has to use their
personal account to --
>>> Is there a way to -- so if you have a
set of employees, is there a way to share
the printer with them or basically make it
available in their preferences so they don't
have to be accepting invitations for this?
>>Akshay Kannan: Absolutely.
So we're working on expanding more of that
going forward, but what you can already currently
do is share it with a group.
So for example, let's say you have a Google
group that encompasses everyone within your
domain.
You can from within the share interface that
we demoed earlier, just type in that group.
And all that needs to happen is the owner
of that group can accept the invitation on
behalf of people in the organization.
>>> Okay.
Thanks.
>>> I develop an application that actually
works like print server, and the printer is
a terminal printer, and I control the printer
by escape comments.
So I open the LPT port and send comments.
How about in that case?
>>Akshay Kannan: So this is with a terminal
printer that you account to over LPR?
>>> Yes, but it's connected to my applications.
There is no drivers, there is no --
>>Akshay Kannan: I see.
If there's no standard print drivers, we won't
be able to integrate that with Cloud Print.
So currently -- I'm assuming you want to set
up the Cloud Print connector from within Chrome
to share it with your Cloud Print account?
In that case we only take the local printers
which are actually in your OS print dialogue
to share.
So we won't be sharing it unless it's -- unless
it uses the standard OS print mechanism to
receive print jobs.
>>> Okay.
But is it -- can I make a connector to the
Google server?
Okay.
>>Akshay Kannan: Yeah.
>>> I remembered the question now.
So you mentioned you can print to your mobile
Nexus, right?
What does that mean?
Like it's just PDF on the flash drive?
>>Akshay Kannan: Exactly.
What we do is we take the job, we convert
it to a PDF and then we push a notification
to your device that starts a download of that
PDF.
So you don't even have to be running Chrome
as Android.
It runs as a background service using Android
push.
So you can print anything to your phone and
it just shows up as a PDF on
the device.
Next questions.
>>> Getting back to the non-cloud-ready printer.
You said you simply do this from a PC or something
like that.
Is there some software you have to load on
to the PC in order for it to act as the server?
I assume it's acting as a cloud-ready server.
>>Akshay Kannan: So currently it works within
Google Chrome.
You have to have Chrome installed on that
PC.
>>> Chrome OS?
>>Akshay Kannan: No, just the Chrome browser.
So from within the settings on Google Chrome
you can configure your local printers to be
cloud ready.
And there's no additional software apart from
Google Chrome required.
>>> So then it acts as a cloud-ready server.
>>Akshay Kannan: Exactly.
>>> Okay.
>>> One more.
Can you tell us about Cloud Print integration
with Google Apps, like sharing to groups,
et cetera?
>>Akshay Kannan: Yeah.
In terms of apps integration, we do support
-- is this for enterprise in particular?
>>> Yeah.
>>Akshay Kannan: Yeah.
For enterprise integration we have -- currently
our consumer solution for most part is our
enterprise solution.
There are plans to move that into a more custom
enterprise solution going forward.
But yeah, for now integration we offer at
a basic level is -- as we mentioned you can
configure Chrome to run as a headless server
on Linux and then also with group sharing
you can easily share printers with groups
of people.
>>> So if that's -- if you add a new user
to a group, if we have a group called printers
and we have five or ten printers connected
to that group and you add a new user to that
group, would he automatically have the print
when he log on to his new account?
>>Yuri Dolgov: Yes.
>>> Okay.
Excellent, thanks.
>>Akshay Kannan: Cool.
Do we have one more?
All right.
Last question.
>>> Normally the driverless printing is a
myth, used to be, but you guys has really
done a good job that it can be a reality.
I really appreciate that.
>>Akshay Kannan: Thank you.
>>Yuri Dolgov: Thank you.
>>Akshay Kannan: Thank you so much.
Thanks a lot, everyone.
[ Applause ]